what's up everybody carlos here okay
we've been waiting on this one
for a minute now the new trailer for
spider-man no way home
i mean we've seen the leaks we've talked
about what we think is going to be in
this trailer if you want to see like our
video on that um you know we'll link
that one down below if you have to watch
if you if you see it and you agree with
what we say or not whatever but the
interesting thing about this
is i think people think they know what's
going to happen already before we even
watch it because we've seen so many
leagues people have been talking about
is andrew in this there's toby in this
and there's been
a lot of denying that and speculation i
mean like
this is one of the most highly
anticipated marvel movies sony movies
spider-man movies in history and
everyone's talking about they know
what's going on or they think they know
what's going on you know i'm not going
to talk about it anymore let's just
watch this trailer together um this will
be my first time seeing it
and then you know
we'll talk about it after okay
oh oh alexa
that's the trailer for the trailer
trailer
okay
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one yeah we've seen this
already public enemy number one where my
life is felt normal
that was when you found out oh it's
peter's secret
talking about the secrets
secret identity
when you botch that spell
everyone thank you for the peter parker
spiderman
we started getting some visitors
we need to watch that spell okay so
again we've seen this already is a
pumpkin bomb from every
universe an actual green goblin oh the
black
suit okay just more views on the same
stuff more or less hello peter
i still like that
that's cool
you're not peter parker
sorry what was your name again dr otto
octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
is he teaming up there are others
so
scooby do this crap scuba diving
you're a mess i know a couple magic
words myself starting with the word
please
please
scooby-doo this crap
at the end
doctor strange takes this mask off and
it's revealed to be mephisto underneath
right that's a scooby-doo reference to
fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate they all die
like the villains
they're a danger to our universe
you're not going to take this away from
me
oh he's got the hmm
you're struggling
to have
everything you want on the boat
almost
[Applause]
hmm what's happening
they're starting to come through
but i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday spider monday huh okay
okay so first thing
we don't get
any like reveal of toby or andrews
uh spiderman there peter in this like
there's no
like confirmation confirmation that
they're in it people will still be
talking about it though that's for sure
um
all right so this whole thing about
doctor strange
that
there's a joke in there about scooby-doo
and i hope that means the scooby-doo's
names to you
well who knows but
there's been talk this chatter online
for a while now about how doctor strange
doesn't seem like himself like he seems
like
something's off
and the talk has been that it's
it's actually mephisto in disguise
and in this trailer i am getting a bit
of that like he feels a little bit off
in some parts of it but in other parts
of it he does
pretty much seem like himself maybe
there is room for a bit of both there
like mephisto is a trickster and we've
been talking about memphis for ages and
ages and you just who even knows if he's
ever going to show up
but um if this is based
you know in fact on on one more day
which you guys know the the this
spreader answer is one more day and if
you if you don't know um
peter makes a deal with mephisto to save
aunt me his life but then it costs them
his his marriage now he's obviously not
married to mj in this one
but you know i mean people hated one
more day but
okay i'm getting ahead of myself
what i'm saying is
i still think it's kind of like a 50 50
chance that doctor strange isn't
official or somehow leads to memphis
doing this one i'm almost so tired of
saying pistol at this point the villains
look cool doc ock's arms his
his octopus arms look amazing alfred
molina like
legend one of the best ever i'm a little
bit confused about the relationship
there in spider-man 2 it did start off
as like a mentor apprentice
relationship and so otto might still
have affection or sympathy or one way or
another for peter even if this isn't his
peter so i could see them
sort of having that you can see that
here in this trailer do they team up and
fight alongside each other who knows i
don't know
uh but it's cool to see like a more sort
of comics accurate say electro sandman
looks like a big giant head i've seen
that before lizard great i know there's
a lot going on what do you think did you
like the trailer was it was everything
you hoped it would be or were you like a
little underwhelmed i'd love to hear
what your theories are
about what's going on in this thing
down below oh and yeah and they're doing
the whole mj falling off the bridge
thing peter jumping to savor which is
obviously a mirror of what happens with
uh with gwen and amazing and this is mj
and actually the original spider-man
movies um
there's a lot going on in here there's a
lot let's talk about it i mean i'm not
talking about it you all can talk about
it let us know what you think that's it
for me
you